we start with the end of a long campaign
tomorrow is
election day thousands of you will head
to the ballots tomorrow
but you can still drop off your mail-in
ballot today we have bianca holman live
with us
to share some of those last minute
reminders bianca
even though early in-person voting ended
on friday you can still put your ballot
in the mail
or drop it off in person at the clark
county elections office in north las
vegas
now because of the pandemic more than a
million people have voted by mail or
cast their ballots during the early
voting period
all active and registered voters were
sent their ballots in late september
or early october the elections office
still expects a big turnout on tuesday
monday we only have one facility
available it's only here at our office
965 trade drive
we'll be completely focused on making
sure that we're ready for election day
on election day the full vote center
allocation will be providing that and
yes we do expect
a number of voters to take advantage of
that a reminder to all voters
do not wait in line with those who are
wanting to vote in person
come to the front there'll be a staffer
there with a ballot box to make sure
it's sealed and that you've signed it
now once your ballot is in the mail or
dropped off you will not receive a
confirmation there are tools however for
you to check
the status of the ballot the secretary
of state offers a ballot tracker and the
elections department offers registered
voter
services on the website you can log in
and check the status
of the mail ballot or call 702 455
vote again if you'd like to drop off
your ballot in person today you can do
so
at the elections office in north las
vegas or of course you can wait till
tomorrow on tuesday to drop it off at
any polling location
and of course we will again be having
updates throughout the day reporting
bianca holman 8 news now